it's like they have magical powers when
the weather warms fruit flies just
appear out of nowhere next to the fruit
bowl near the trash everywhere and once
they arrive they are determined to stay
no matter how many you swat squash or
sees now as far as we know fruit flies
can't teleport into our homes from
another grosser dimension so where do
they come from and why they so hard to
get rid of meet Drosophila melanogaster
your standard fruit fly it could smell a
meal for more than a kilometer away all
thanks to the tiny antenna on top of its
head these antennae are specially
attuned to sniff out chemicals like
acetic acid led off by rotting fruit and
once they're locked onto the scent it's
nearly impossible to keep them out of
your home that's because fruit flies are
about the size of a sesame seed so they
can slip through almost any crack screen
or gap but contrary to popular belief
it's not just the smelly fruit they're
after they're also hunting for the
source of that rotting stench
specifically fungi and other
microorganisms YUM and once they land
for the feast things turn even nastier
you know how you never see just one
fruit fly that's because they have
incredibly fast life cycles a single
female fruit fly can lay up to 100 eggs
a day which hatch in less than 24 hours
the maggots then tunnel under the fruit
skin feeding on the microbial rot in
just a few days later they pupate into
fully fledged fruit flies by the time
day 11 or 12 rolls around they're ready
to have little maggots of their own oh
that's why your home can go from fruit
fly free to infested in under two weeks
now by this point you might start
swatting them down one by one but it's
not so easy right perhaps even fruitless
well sign
have discovered why turns out fruit
flies are mathematical Wizards of escape
for starters they have around 270 degree
vision so they can see you coming from
almost any angle front back or side to
side and they will actually calculate
the angle of your attack and plan their
escape accordingly all in as little as
100 milliseconds scientists figure this
out because of how a resting fruit fly
will reposition its legs when it senses
an attack if your hands coming from the
front
for example fruit flies move their
middle legs forward lean back and raise
their legs allowing for a fast backwards
take off once in midair killing them
isn't much easier they can change
directions within 1/100 of a second and
quickly accelerate by flapping their
wings 200 times per second not bad for a
brain that's even smaller than a house
flies so then how do you get rid of them
some experts suggest making a trap fill
a container with 2 centimeters of cider
vinegar cap it with a funnel and then
take around the perimeter so that no
flies can crawl out you see fruit flies
are smart enough to find fruit but not
the hole they entered but here's the
thing even if you trap every last fly
they will come back as long as there's
something to eat and unfortunately for
you fruit flies aren't picky they love
rotten fruit sure but wine and other
fermented liquids which are chock-full
of those microbes they adore are also
tasty as is the slime that builds up in
your kitchen sink so really the only
thing you can do to get rid of them is
to well clean up
you